Hola en los últimos videos hemos
resuelto algunos problemas de movimiento
de proyectiles quizás se vieron un poco
más complicados de lo que en realidad
son porque he manejado todo en términos
de variables Ahora quiero que tomemos
todo lo que espero que hayan aprendido
en los últimos videos y nos pongamos a
resolver varios problemas Pues creo que
es lo mejor para adquirir experiencia y
entendimiento de estos conceptos vamos a
resolver un problema directo regresemos
al juego de lanzar la pelota digamos que
lanzo una ota hacia
arriba hacia
arriba con un
tiempo igual a 7
segundos qué tan rápido la lancé hacia
arriba y Qué tan alto llegó tenemos
muchas fórmulas que podemos usar para
resolver este problema en 10 segundos o
incluso en 2 segundos pero lo que quiero
hacer es usar la misma lógica de cuando
inferimos las fórmulas pero trabaja
trando ahora con números y les mostraré
que no necesitamos memorizar estas
fórmulas Entonces tenemos estos
datos y bueno el tiempo total de que
cayó esta pelota cuando la lancé fue de
7 segundos entonces asumiendo que no hay
resistencia al aire tenemos que la misma
cantidad de tiempo que le tomó a la
pelota llegar hasta arriba será la misma
cantidad de tiempo que le tomó llegar
hasta el suelo Entonces tenemos que
nuestra pelota bueno
originalmente fue hacia arriba y cayó y
ese tiempo le tomó 7 segundos Entonces
ahora asumiendo que no tenemos
resistencia al aire vamos a ver que el
tiempo desde que yo lancé la pelota
hasta que llegó hasta arriba y se detuvo
es la mitad del tiempo total entonces
son
3.5
segundos
entonces Bueno qué nos dice esto Bueno
nos dice que la pelota tardó 3.5
segundos de llegar a una velocidad cero
cuando se detiene hasta arriba partiendo
de una velocidad inicial cualquiera que
est haya sido cuando yo la lancé hacia
arriba y
entonces le tardó 3.5 segundos en
detenerse por completo en el aire
Entonces mi velocidad final es igual a
cer este cero padre esce la pelota que
lancé Pero bueno es un
cero ni siquiera tenemos que pensar en
alguna fórmula pensemos intuitivamente
qué tan rápido estoy
desacelerando bueno deseler en relación
a la gravedad porque Bueno eso es lo que
sucede es lo que ocurre para que nuestra
pelota esté deteniéndose o vaya más
lento una vez que la lanzamos recordemos
que nuestra
aceleración vamos a poner en otro color
la aceleración de la gravedad es de - 10
m sobre segundo cuadrado y es menos
porque nos está jalando hacia el suelo
entonces Eh bueno Qué vamos a hacer
ahora la aceleración es lo mismo que el
cambio de
velocidad y la aceleración por el tiempo
es lo mismo que el cambio en velocidad o
si lo quieren ver como el cambio en
velocidad dividido entre el tiempo es lo
mismo que la aceleración
Entonces recordemos cuál es nuestra
diferencia en velocidades bueno nuestra
diferencia en
velocidad es igual a la velocidad final
Ay velocidad final menos velocidad
inicial y aquí Bueno tenemos la
velocidad final es cer0 Entonces tenemos
que esto es igual a 0 menos nuestra
velocidad inicial que bueno es la que
todavía nos conocemos y además sabemos
que este cambio en velocidades igual a
la aceleración por el tiempo y ambos
datos los tenemos Entonces tenemos que
nuestra velocidad nuestro cambio de
velocidad es igual a la aceleración por
el
tiempo que es igual a nuestra
aceleración de -10 m sobre segundo al
cuadrado por nuestro tiempo que es la
mitad del periodo en que subió y bajó
que es de
3.5 segundos entonces multiplicamos y
nos queda como 10 * 3 5 es igual a
35 m y este segundo que multiplica me
anula uno de los segundos que está abajo
dividiendo 35 m por segundo y uniendo
estas dos despejes o estas dos fórmulas
tenemos que nuestra menos velocidad
inicial es igual a
-35 m sobre Segundo si multiplicamos
todo por -1 nos queda que nuestra
velocidad inicial es igual a 35
metros por segundo Y esta es cómo
encontramos nuestros datos esta fórmula
de velocidad final menos velocidad
inicial realmente ni podemos verlo como
fórmula es algo muy obvio entonces bueno
simplemente podemos decir que lanzamos
algo a cierta velocidad y le tomó la
mitad del tiempo total de subir y bajar
en llegar a cero en quedarse eh quieta
en el aire le le tomó 3.5 segundos
llegar a una velocidad
cer0 y está desacelerando a la razón de
una aceleración de -10 m por segundo
cuadrado Así que cada segundo se está
haciendo 10 m por segundo más lento y
cada segundo que pasa esto está
ocurriendo Entonces si le
tomó un tiempo de
3.5 Mr perdón de 3.5 segundos para
llegar a cer0 entonces debió de haber
iniciado a una velocidad de 35 m/s si
esto los confunde usen las fórmulas pero
vean que pueden usar su intuición cada
segundo que viaje en el aire se hace 10
m por segundo más lenta la pelota y si
le tomó 3.5 segundos de pasar de
cualquier velocidad que haya sido
nuestra velocidad inicial a cer0
entonces debió iniciar con una velocidad
de 35 m por segundo si tenemos que
la vez que pasó un segundo cuando
nuestro tiempo es igual a un segundo la
pelota iba a 25 m por
segundo cuando pasaron 2
segundos nuestra pelota iba a 15 m por
segundo esto lo estoy usando con cada eh
que cada segundo se desacelera 10 m por
segundo cuando pasaron 3 segundos la
velocidad de mi pelota eran de 5 m por
segund seg y cuando llega a
3.5 segundos la velocidad es
cer0 entonces Bueno ahora veamos Qué tan
alto llegó mi
pelota bueno recordamos que el tiempo
total fue de 7 segundos nuestra
aceleración es de 10 - 10 m por segundo
cuadrado y ahora tenemos la velocidad
inicial que fue de 35 m por segundo eso
es muy intuitivo y ni siquiera deberemos
verlo también como otra fórmula
tenemos que el cambio en distancia o la
diferencia en distancias es igual a la
velocidad promedio por el
tiempo Entonces esto lo podemos percibir
como algo de sentido común si ponemos eh
números tenemos que nuestro cambio en
distancia es igual a la velocidad
promedio es la velocidad inicial más la
velocidad final entre
dos por el tiempo que recordemos es la
mitad del periodo Ah Me faltó la d de
distancia Entonces tenemos que esto es
igual a bueno la velocidad final es cer0
la velocidad inicial es de 35
m sobre segundo entre 2 por el tiempo
que es de
3.5
segundos
entonces usamos nuestra calculadora y
hacemos 35
ent
2 esto por
3.5 segundos y nos queda
61.25 Entonces el cambio en distancia o
la altura a la que llego es de se me
olvida
61.25
metr entonces pues como ven Fue bastante
fácil Espero que con esto vean que
usando números no esan encontrar la
solución y bueno en los siguientes
videos Seguiremos resolviendo problemas
y ya vamos a usar problemas un poco
diferentes a este de lanzar la pelota
bueno los veo
pronto